the next big technology Society Clash
was when AI algorithms were used for
decision making they would train they
still are they would train on data and
then become make decisions for us or
advise our decisions like in criminal
justice or credit worthiness or and so
forth and so on and though these
algorithms are used widely but most
people don't even know they're part of
making decisions they can't explain
their decisions and if they're trained
on bias data they just produce bias
results because that they're just
replicating statistically what what they
were trained to do but even though they
look like there's going to be impartial
so this that's sort of the next wave the
third wave has been around
misinformation and disinformation and
the use of that information the spread
of it on social media we don't really
know how to establish truthful content
at scale or what trust means at scale or
moderation at scale we haven't figured
any of those out around the issue of
moderation so those are three major
tidal waves and now comes generative AI
the dis the time between them is shorter
between privacy and algorithmic uh
fairness was was one time but but only a
couple of years later before we got to
the issues around democracy and only a
few years later shorter than that before
we get to these issues around generative
AI so these clashes are coming faster
and the truth is even though data
privacy goes back to 1997 we still don't
know the answer we still don't have a
solution I think the the question is how
do we maintain our control of our lives
our society you know the all of these
changes by technology are changing the
way we live and work and play but
they're also making the rules that we
live by
and the question is we no longer it's
not a rule makers increasingly or the
laws that we have that determine our
rules but how these the design of these
Technologies and how do we restore uh
sort of control over that